Speaker 1: We're really learning a ton this
week about how you can lie with graphs, lie
with charts, lie with statistics, and we're
learning all of it from from Fox News.
Earlier this week, I showed you a completely
deceptive chart which presented the opposite
of the truth with regard to America's healthiest
and unhealthiest cities.
That was earlier this week today.
I'm going to show you a clip, which is really
a masterclass in how to deceptively use statistics.
Tucker Carlson hosted Charlie Kirk on his
program.
Charlie Kirk is sort of like a right wing
indoctrinate leader of college kids, I guess
is the way I would say it through an organization
called Turning Point USA.
Now, Charlie Kirk has no medical knowledge
or expertize whatsoever.
And he appeared on the Tucker Carlson program
and argued that vaccines might increase deaths.
COVID vaccines might increase deaths.
Now, before we even start the clip, I'm going
to remind you that that's not true.
It's not true.
But look at how they frame the data to create
that possibility.
OK, let's let's listen here.
Speaker 2: So here's a shocking story like
you should care no matter what side you're
on, above all about how Americans are doing.
And one of the main measures of how they're
doing is how long they live.
If you're dying younger, there's a problem,
and a lot of them are dying younger.
This fact comes to us from the life insurance
companies, which keep close track of that
have noticed this according to their data,
according to Scott Davidson, the CEO of One
American Assurance.
Reported deaths in the age range, by the way.
Speaker 1: No No.
One America Insurance doesn't have anything
to do with one America news.
Just just so everybody's clear
Speaker 2: 18 to 64.
Those are the working years.
We're up 40 percent in the third quarter of
last year compared to pre-pandemic and pre
vaccine totals.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, it's 16 to 64.
That's an important aspect of this and what
Speaker 2: we are seeing right now, the highest
death rates we have seen in the history of
this business, not just at one America.
40 percent is just unheard of.
And again, these are the guys who do this
for a living, and they're shocked.
So the question what's causing this?
It's clear our leaders don't think COVID is
to blame here.
Stacey Abrams maskless in front of a roomful
of mass children, and she has at least one
very obvious comorbidity.
Here's Barack Obama maskless in the face of
his mask servants as they build this latest
mansion in Hawaii.
So if corona is not causing these deaths and
is not what is causing these deaths, 40 percent
increase.
Charlie Kirk is the co-founder of Turning
Point USA.
Just wrote a piece on this.
That's why,
Speaker 1: first of all, why on earth would
you have Charlie Kirk on to talk about this?
It makes no sense at all.
Speaker 2: We learned about it.
He joins us tonight to assess Charlie Kirk.
Thanks so much for coming on.
What is this?
Thank you.
We don't know.
I mean, one business that actually tells the
truth regarding the death of Americans is
life insurance.
They have to get this right.
They have entire teams of actuaries that study
this data all your all day long.
It's not the public health authorities that
are warning it this.
It's a single CEO of a major life insurance
company says, Hey, by the way, there's kind
of a 40 percent increase in death.
10 percent, he said, would be a once in 200
year catastrophe.
We have a 40 percent increase in death.
And it's not because of COVID, and we deserve
answers.
And what's so amazing, Tucker, is that we've
known this information and this data for a
couple of weeks now.
Where are the politicians?
Where are the leaders?
Where are the people we put in charge to actually
care about the well-being of our people?
Well, at least we know how many times Joe
Rogan used a bad word in a podcast the last
10 years.
I guess we're getting our pronouns right for
our six year olds, but we have a 40 percent
increase in death among the supposed healthiest
portion of the American population.
This is a catastrophe.
We deserve answers, and some would conjecture.
Hey, does this have something to do with the
fact that we might have done a mass inoculation
strategy?
We know that there was deaths of alienation,
suicide and otherwise, but there's no answers.
No one's talking about it.
So I mean, isn't this the primary number they
should be focused on?
If you're in charge of the well-being of the
American people and the death rate jumps by
40 percent in a cohort?
You know, that's not supposed to die young,
then like, why aren't you hair on fire upset
about it?
I'm honestly confused.
Well, it's either they don't care or they
don't know how to talk about it, or they are
too concerned about GDP numbers or stock market
increases or immigration quotas or whatever.
It's a mass casualty event.
It's that simple.
And the fact that the insurance company.
Speaker 1: So listen, this this is really
a masterclass in deceptive use of of statistics.
So so you really have to break this down in
parts covered back, he talks about the mass
inoculation campaign.
Maybe it's something we need to look at here.
COVID vaccines protect you from COVID death.
They're very, very good at that.
But they say, well, vaccines happened and
deaths went up.
What's going on?
Maybe the vaccines are part of this.
You have to critically analyze the primary
sources, and when you do, you realize that
this has been studied extensively?
First of all, it is the right that loves to
say a lot of the people that supposedly died
of COVID didn't really die of COVID, they
died of something else.
Now you and I have already discussed, well,
COVID can cause someone to die due to some
intervening or intermediate condition.
COVID in many of the people that die triggers
a separate illness that eventually leads to
death.
It can cause cardiac issues.
It can cause respiratory issues.
It all sorts of different things.
They are the ones who were telling us a lot
of the people supposedly dying of COVID aren't
really dying of COVID, they're dying about
other stuff.
Here are some of those people are in these
statistics.
Some of these people are the people that the
right wingers have been saying they shouldn't
be classifying as dying of COVID because they're
actually technically dying of other stuff.
Well, that's what you're seeing in the data.
When they say even not counting COVID, you
see these people dying.
It's the people you've been talking about
that didn't quote really die of COVID.
That's one piece of this second piece of this.
We know that due to two things one, for a
while, all non-emergency care being delayed
in the health care system.
And number two, because a lot of people say,
I don't want to go to a medical facility right
now, I've got that ache.
I've got that symptom.
I don't.
I'm going to delay this screening or that
that screening.
We know that conditions, for example, like
cancer are on average being diagnosed later
when you diagnose cancer later.
The treatment options are more limited.
They're less likely to be effective and your
death rate is going to be up.
So that's also a real thing here and the irresponsibility
of saying, I don't know the mass inoculation
campaign we got to be thinking about it is
not only irresponsible, but I think they even
know that it's not true.
I don't think there's any way.
Charlie Kirk, I don't know.
But Tucker Carlson, there's no way Tucker
Carlson thinks that the reason the death rate
is up is because of vaccination.
There's there's just no way and they're jumping
around.
It's not even they're jumping three steps
ahead, they're just jumping three steps in
any direction and connecting things for which
there are not actually connections.
And it's irresponsible, and it's part of the
continued disinformation that is being spread
on Fox News.